vamos a resolver el siguiente problema
dice sea omega una raíz cúbica compleja
de la unidad con omega distinto de uno
que uno es justamente la unidad dice un
dado justo y esto es un dado que no hace
trampa de soldado que no tiene
predilección por ningún número en
particular dice que un dado justo es
lanzado tres veces cierre uno
r2 y r3 son los números que se obtienen
en el dado entonces la probabilidad de
que omega a la r1 más omega elevado a la
r2 más omega elevado a la r3 es igual a
cero es es decir nos están preguntando
la probabilidad de que esta expresión
sea 0 hizo un problema fascinante
entonces lo primero que vamos a hacer es
tratar esta primera parte es decir ver
cuáles son las raíces cúbicas de la
unidad y ver si si manejando los podemos
obtener algunos patrones que nos ayuden
a resolver el problema entonces si
estamos hablando de números que nos dan
una bueno que que son este raíces
cúbicas de uno quiere decir que
si lo elevamos ese número al cubo esto
nos debe dar 1 muy bien o lo que es lo
mismo que x al cubo menos 1 es igual a
cero eso es lo que nos está diciendo que
sean raíces cúbicas esto por supuesto lo
también lo podemos decir que la raíz
cúbica de x es igual a 1 son todas son
formas equivalentes de decir exactamente
lo mismo
ok entonces algo que sí sabemos es que
uno su raíz cúbica es 1 entonces x igual
a 1 es una raíz es una raíz de uno de
este polinomio como quieran verlo
entonces lo que sabemos es que cuando
tenemos una raíz
justamente podemos factorizar este
polinomio con un un término lineal que
esencialmente pues se vería entonces
como x menos 1 por otro polinomio aquí y
que de hecho escuadra tico es de orden 2
entonces vamos a ponerle x por una
cuadrática digamos una un polinomio
cuadrática
expresión cuadrática y esto debe ser
igual a 0 muy bien entonces fíjense que
si queremos encontrar las raíces cúbicas
de de 1 necesitamos saber quién es esta
cuadrática para factorizar la y saber
quién es bueno para resolverla y
resolver cuáles son las raíces de esta
expresión cuadrática muy bien entonces
como lo obtenemos pues es muy sencillo
simplemente hay que dividir esta
expresión entre x menos 1 y nos debe dar
esta otra verdad muy bien entonces vamos
a hacerlo x menos 1 x menos 1 va a
dividir a x al cubo menos 1 pero x al
cubo menos 1 aquí va x al cubo voy a
dejar un espacio para x cuadrada un
espacio para x y hasta acá vamos a poner
el menos 1 este espacio es justamente
para que todo se pueda calcular
fácilmente muy bien entonces la pregunta
es cuántas veces cabe x en x cúbica y
entonces necesitamos un x cuadrada
verdad de tal suerte que x cuadrada por
x es x cúbica y menos
por equis cuadrada es menos x cuadrada
pero bueno como vamos a restar le
ponemos aquí un menos y aquí un más y
esto que nos da esto se cancelan y me
queda x cuadrada y tengo que bajar el
menos uno verdad entonces ahora me
pregunto cuántas veces cabe x en x
cuadrada y en esta ocasión pues cada x
veces verdad x x x va a ser x cuadrada
x nada más entonces x x x es x cuadrada
si ponemos x cuadrada y x x menos 1 es
menos x verdad ahora bien como vamos a
restar lo pues les cambiamos el signo a
todos y volvemos a sumar y estos se
cancelan y me queda x menos 1 y ahora
nos preguntamos cuántas veces cabe x
menos 1 en x menos 1 y eso claramente es
una vez verdad y nuestro residuo que
será 0 y eso y eso tiene mucho sentido
tenemos un residuo cero porque en efecto
x menos 1 es una raíz perdón x menos 1
es un factor porque x por qué porque
era una raíz cúbica de una raíz de este
polinomio muy bien entonces lo que
estamos diciendo es que x cúbica menos 1
se puede escribir como x menos 1 por
nuestra cuadrática por nuestra expresión
cuadrática y ese es s es x cuadrada más
x + 1 muy bien
y esto por supuesto tiene que ser igual
a 0 porque esta expresión la original
era igual a 0 muy bien entonces si
queremos encontrar las raíces de esta
expresión pues ya tenemos una que es uno
verdad tenemos un producto de dos
números que nos da cero pues algunos de
ellos tienen que ser cero si éste es
cero ya vimos que x es igual a uno pero
si éste es cero en realidad tenemos que
resolver la ecuación x cuadrada más x
más uno igual a cero y esa es una
ecuación cuadrática muy bien y eso pues
tenemos una fórmula muy agradable para
encontrar cualquier raíz verdad
simplemente tomamos que x sería igual a
menos 1 bueno menos este coeficiente
menos uno más menos la raíz cuadrada de
b cuadrada que en este caso es uno menos
cuatro a porsche pero a es 1 y c es 1
así que 4 ac es 44 simplemente y todo
esto dividido entre 2 a 0 a es 1
entonces sí
reescribimos bien esto esto es menos 1
más menos la raíz de menos 3 entre 2 y
el hecho de que sea la raíz con la raíz
cuadrada de un número negativo y lo que
hace que estas raíces sean complejas
verdad estas raíces son complejas de
hecho lo que sabemos es que la raíz de
menos 3 pues lo pueden ver más o menos
como que esto es la raíz de menos 1 por
la raíz de 3 muy bien y entonces esto la
raíz de menos 1 es es y y esto esto de
aquí es justamente y esto es raíz de
tres muy bien entonces
lo reescribimos x será igual a menos 1 +
menos raíz de 3 por iu y déjenme ponerlo
con otro color para que sea muy claro
qué es lo que estamos haciendo y ahora
dividimos todo entre 2 muy bien ok
entonces aquí tenemos nuestras otras dos
raíces cúbicas dos raíces bueno son
raíces cúbicas de 1 verdad entonces
estas dos raíces resulta que si los
elevamos al cubo son 1 así que ya
sabemos todas la primera es 1 la segunda
es menos 1 + raíz de 3 y entre 2 y la
tercera raíz es menos 1 - la raíz de 3 y
entre 2 ok entonces si nos piden bueno
nos piden que tomemos omega una raíz
cúbica compleja de la unidad que no sea
1 ok
nos tomamos una omega raíz cúbica
compleja de la unidad que no es 1
entonces ésta no la podemos tomar
tenemos que tomarnos a alguno de estos y
el problema como que nos dice que no va
a importar cuál
realmente verdad entonces digamos nos
como queremos ver potencias es alguno de
estos números elevado a las potencias
pues no sé r1 r2 r3 que son los los
números que pueden aparecer en un dado
tenemos que elegir nos uno vamos a
elegir por ejemplo vamos a tomar nuestra
omega
omega digamos con el signo que será
negativo ok voy a distribuir este 2 esto
lo podemos ver como menos un medio menos
la raíz de 3 entre 2 y esto es
exactamente una de estas raíces muy bien
entonces ya que hemos elegido este vamos
a ver qué pasa con este número si lo
vamos elevando algunas potencias por
ejemplo quién sería omega cuadrada omega
cuadrada pues simplemente sería menos un
medio menos la raíz de 3 entre 2 y que
se multiplica asimismo menos un medio
menos la raíz de 3 entre 2 y muy bien
si me quedo muy grande ahí está entonces
ya sabemos muy bien cómo multiplicar
números complejos verdad y si no revisa
las listas de números complejos así que
esto simplemente es menos un medio por
menos un medio es un cuarto verdad el
menos con el menos se hacen más ahora
menos un medio por menos tres medios y
eso son más tres raíz de tres entre dos
por dos que son cuatro y ahora tomamos
este y lo multiplicamos con este y
tenemos menos por menos es más
raíz de tres por uno en raíz de tres y
abajo queda dos por dos es cuatro y nos
falta multiplicar por nuestra y y
finalmente tenemos que multiplicar este
número por este número que es
esencialmente el mismo entonces el menos
con el menos se hace más aquí voy a
dejar ok voy a dejar el más raíz de 3 x
raíz de 3 pues es 3 y esto lo dividimos
entre 2 por 2 que es 4 y luego tenemos y
por y pero y por y es menos 1 así que
tenemos que está en realidad fue - ahí
lo tenemos como simplificamos esto esto
lo podemos simplificar de la siguiente
forma por ejemplo bueno vamos a hacerlo
esto es un cuarto y aquí tenemos dos
veces la misma expresión tenemos raíz de
tres entre cuatro y más raíz entre más
raíz de tres entre cuatro y pues eso
simplemente es raíz de tres entre dos y
verdad muy bien entonces qué más nos
falta y nos falta restar tres cuartos y
esto todavía lo podemos simplificar más
verdad porque un cuarto menos tres
cuartos
es menos o bueno tenemos uno menos tres
son menos dos y menos dos entre cuatro
es menos un medio
la raíz de 3 entre 2 por iu y esto es
muy pero muy interesante porque otra vez
bueno al elevar al cuadrado omega y aquí
quizás no se ve mucho como un omega
ahora si ya se ve al elevar al cuadrado
tuvimos la otra raíz que de hecho la
otra raíz es su propio con jugado muy
bien digo los que han estudiado análisis
complejo o variable compleja sabrán muy
bien por qué es que ocurre todo esto
pero si no no lo ha llevado no lo sabes
o no te acuerdas no pasa nada
simplemente nos estamos dando cuenta de
varias cosas muy pero muy interesantes
entonces ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con
omega al cubo quien sería omega al cubo
bueno al cuadrado no es al cubo al cubo
omega al cubo es omega al cuadrado por
omega pero mega al cuadrado ya lo
obtuvimos omega al cuadrado es y es esto
de aquí
- un medio
la raíz de 3 entre 2 por i
y ahora hay que multiplicar por omega
hay que multiplicar por menos un medio y
cómo definimos omega es este menos un
medio menos la raíz de 3 entre 2 por i
si multiplicamos esto vamos a ver que
nos da entonces por ejemplo tomemos
tomemos este que multiplica este y nos
queda un cuarto verdad menos por menos
es más un medio por un medio es un
cuarto
ahora vamos a multiplicar digamos este
de aquí por este de acá y tenemos menos
por menos es más un medio por esto es
raíz de 3 entre 2 por 2 que es 4 y nos
queda multiplicar por y vamos a
multiplicar ahora este por éste
creo que sí lo hice bien sí sí lo hice
bien entonces tenemos más x menos es
menos raíz de 3 entre 2 por 24 y
multiplicamos por nuestra y y ahora
finalmente vamos a multiplicar este por
este y nos queda más por menos es menos
raíz de 3 por raíz de tres es tres y dos
por dos es cuatro
ahora y por y es menos uno pero con este
menos pues lo podemos hacer más
ahora bien qué es lo que ocurre estos se
cancelan y tengo un cuarto más tres
cuartos son cuatro cuartos que es uno y
esto ya lo sabíamos verdad habíamos
dicho que omega era la raíz cúbica de 1
entonces al elevarlo al cubo pues
obtenemos 1 entonces aquí estamos
comprobando que en efecto hicimos bien
nuestras cuentas ahora ya sabemos muy
bien cómo pueden ser todas las potencias
de omega fíjense que si elevamos a la 1
pues es justamente este número pero si
elevamos al cuadrado es su complejo
conjugado verdad simplemente es
cambiarle el signo a la parte imaginaria
y si elevamos al cubo pues esto será 1
si queremos ver a la 4 pues sería omega
al cubo por omega pero mega al cubo es 1
entonces nos queda omega si queremos ver
a las 5 pues es omega la 4 que es omega
por omega que es omega cuadrada que es
este aquí les dije cosas muy rápidas
sólo haz la prueba de quién es omega da
4 omega la 5 y omega 6 entonces ya
sabemos todas esas potencias que pueden
salir en el dado y eso lo vamos a
utilizar para atacar la solución del
problema
en el próximo vídeo